[Music]
5 6
and welcome to
nland I defy you not to dance to this
song you don't get
all you now go to be officially
interviewed ordinarily we're the ones
asking the question who are
you I name is
Je wrong answer what happened in there
you might have helped me you might have
learned a new skill that made you more
useful and put us on a track toward
growth all right let's get to
work everybody ready to say goodbye to
our solar
system
I'm not here as a
witness
[Music]
mhm what if there was a place a secret
place where nothing is
impossible miraculous
[Music]
place where you could actually change
the
world
[Music]
you want to
go I want to tell you a secret that will
see you through all the trials that life
can offer have courage and be
kind I am in love with
you and I know that love is just a shout
into the void and that Oblivion is
inevitable well we got this
hard okay
[Music]
okay
oh